the public just found out a few years
ago about Caitlyn when she made her
transition but my mom has known for
decades Brody Jenner got real candid on
Monday's episode of the hills new
beginnings he and his mom Linda Thompson
opened up about Caitlyn Jenner my dad
and I have never really had a great
relationship all the ups and downs that
our family has had my mom has definitely
been the rock and made sure that the
family gets together once or twice a
month Brody's wife Caitlyn Carter
revealed Caitlyn Jenner canceled on
attending their wedding the week before
the ceremony
Brody really just kind of brushed it off
but he has to have felt something but he
doesn't express it not having my dad at
the wedding was it was it was about
honestly it really did hurt I would have
loved to have had her there but
apparently Linda also opened up about
how Caitlyn's transition affected her it
was a secret she kept for years I was so
happily married to Bruce Jenner I had
this great normal life here in this
little house in Malibu until that
fateful day standing right over there
where Bruce said to me I'm you know I
want to transition my life just did you
know like a 180 I had just lost my
marriage and the father of my kids I was
devastated but that was just a momentary
reaction my greater sympathy had to go
out took to Caitlyn Wow Linda knew for
decades Caitlyn only told the world in
June 2015 and Brody just revealed when
he first learned the news she never told
me until I was like 27 years old as when
she told me what he was going through
she waited to tell us until you know we
were old enough to understand but it was
was I thought the right thing to do
could Kaitlyn appear on the hills to
address her relationship with her son
are we gonna see any Kardashians any
Jenner's
but this season I don't know you're
gonna have to watch and find out
yeah I'm not really allowed to give away
any other stuff that's on the show maybe
Kaitlyn could appear it's there's always
a possibility rody turns 36 later this
year and him and wife Caitlin are
beginning to talk about starting a
family of their own trying to fatten
Kaitlyn up so she can get her BMI index
up check that baby
do you guys have a timeline are you
talking about expanding the family yeah
I mean we don't have a specific timeline
but we're definitely getting to the
night right after this event timeline
yes we are gonna start trying right over
a bad time to try never know yeah if it
happens it happens and we're we're just
right now we're just focused on all this
but I'm sure our attention will shift
that way
all right guys what did you make of this
episode of the hills do you think we're
gonna get that Kaitlyn Brodie heart to
heart I hope so let me know and for all
the latest keep it locked to all things
et until next time I'm Katie Krause and
bye for now
[Applause]
[Music]